who didn't see this coming a liberal
bail Reform Group backed by woke
celebrities like John Legend Danny
Glover and Sir Richard Branson just shut
down it's Las Vegas chapter for the most
predictable reason you can imagine
this career criminal was released just
after the bail project paid three grand
to bail him out on burglary charges six
days later police say this guy tried to
kill a man opening fire in a Las Vegas
restaurant shooting a waiter 11 times
that winner survived and is now suing
the organization the criminals rap sheet
is a mile long Grand arsony felony
burglary auto theft and that's just in
three short years
all right so Kennedy um is this how we
get these stupid bail projects to stop
is by having people who are injured by
those who are released from the bill
project sued and held financially
accountable is that How This Ends uh
yeah that is actually how all of these
things end it's It's when um someone
realizes that someone else is
accountable for their suffering and they
go after them legally that's the only
thing that will make people sit up and
pay attention uh some bail practices in
this country have been horrific and have
taken good people and put them in the
system and eventually put them in prison
for minor infractions those people
should not be caught up in that people
who are violent recidivist criminals who
mean to do a great deal of harm they
should not be the ones who benefit from
bail reform that is not Criminal Justice
Reform that is ignoring victims that is
making cities far less safe and it is
such an unsophisticated way of dealing
with very very serious problems and they
don't want to go these people should be
in prison these people should not be in
prison yes we do over incarcerate in
this country but that's not the way you
fix it and Jessica do liberals learn the
lesson because you have you know you
know built-in levers I mean a judge and
a D.A they're held accountable by voters
but also if Grandma or your parents come
in and pay your bail or Bond
um they're gonna go Hey listen you're
going to follow the rules you're going
to show up in court you have someone
looking over your shoulder but when you
have an outside group that that the
criminal doesn't know and they're sprung
by that group there's really no
accountability do liberals kind of get
the message that hey communities are
less safe when we let these folks out of
jail not more safe well certainly in
this instance right the group has been
shut down now and they did have a high
uh show up for court rate there was 91
percent of people that they had bailed
out had shown up it's pretty good odds
right that someone is coming but the
thing that was most disturbing to me
about this particular case is this guy
was a schizophrenic he had been
diagnosed it was known it was part of
his record and he was bailed out and not
taken to a Treatment Center or somewhere
else it was just released back on the
street and we know that one of the main
problems with the homeless population
are mental health issues that's what's
going on all over these big cities in
Los Angeles and New York Chicago San
Francisco so it's a real failing on the
part of this group and like Kennedy
there's no one-size-fits-all solution
for this
there are a lot of people who don't
deserve to be in jail because they can't
pay this low bail amount and there are a
lot of people who do deserve to be kept
in jail with no bail available to them
until the end and until we find a more
nuanced way and I know people make fun
of me Democrats loves to say oh we need
a little Nuance but until we find a
nuanced way to deal with this you you
can't make these blanket laws like what
Illinois did was you know
yeah no bail in in Paris I mean I look
at this and say Well it had this do good
bail bail bail group not stepped in and
paid the bail this guy would have still
been in jail and not shot this of this
waiter up 11 times and now this
defendant isn't going to be out what in
a year for the first charges he's
actually got an 18-year prison sentence
because he tried to uh commit homicide
tried failed miserably 11 times wow
um
here's the here's my biggest problem
with this we celebrities Love The Virtue
signal right and we're talking about the
chapters shut down and the celebrities
just washed their hands for a bit and
walk away but if you're going to stand
behind something if you're going to
spawn if you're going to show up and put
your face on and get people to to donate
and support it when something like this
happens you need to be accountable just
like are you talking about Grandma or
Mom bails you out they usually have to
put their house up or something of that
manage well these celebrities need to
start putting things up to support
things because here's the deal they
might start looking at who's on the list
you know and they'll be like you know
what oh this guy's been arrested 17
times yeah he's not a candidate
opposed to this person who has never had
a violent offender but seems to be at
the wrong place at the wrong time and
unpaid trafficking or whatever the
reason was had a warrant for not that's
the guy you help out the non-violent the
non the guys who aren't robbing and
pillaging
but there's no accountability for The
Virtue signaling so what they do they
didn't shut they just shut down one
chapter for a little while then they'll
change the name and they'll show up
somewhere else and that's not and then
they'll go but overall Legend is not
going to be held accountable for this
he's not gonna have to answer questions
well soon they win I mean but it's not a
ton of money but I think it's been sued
for fifteen thousand but they have
insurances for that and this those type
of things he's they're going to keep
this is a problem virtue signaling has
to have a price tag on it if you're
going to support these reforms and
you're gonna then you need to be held
accountable for it if you want to put
your name on it to take the credit like
look at all the good I've done look at
all the people I've helped yeah oh four
of those people did horrible things
that's on me you should have been a
billboard okay I mean it seems like
Democrats have a cesspool of bad ideas
so we had no bail in New York no bail in
New Jersey and those policies have
failed crime has skyrocketed and so what
has Illinois done with all the Liberals
they said listen we should do the same
thing but go even further no cash bail
in Illinois look they're they're making
a choice based on their ideology you
know if you look at the ideology of
these of these soft prosecutors they
believe that criminals have these kinds
of Rights because the system in America
the judicial system has flaws whether
it's racism or there's too much funding
for the police they genuinely believe
that it's an ideology which is why
you're continuing to see them doing it
they don't actually care about victims
rights they don't care about the people
who are affected here thank God this
person survived after being shot 11
times but there's a lot of people who
haven't survived as a result of this and
people who are shot are injured for life
and their lives are changed forever and
if you look at the record here of the
the criminal he was arrested in November
2020 21 for burglary and theft well a
lot of people would argue that's
non-violent Behavior right so therefore
he should be let out on bond he should
you know not have severe consequences if
you allow non-violent crimes or crimes
that are not as serious to go on
undeterred or unpunished they turn into
bigger crimes like walking into a
restaurant and shooting a waiter it's a
broken window Siri that we've seen work
in a lot of places like New York City
when there wasn't CRI as much crime as
there is now so it's all about
deterrence it's all about making sure
that people understand if they've commit
crimes whether it's non-violent or not
there's a punishment for it and as you
said having consequences for people
actually having skin in the game because
these celebrities don't have to deal
with this they live in gated communities
they don't care if the waiter who works
at the restaurant that they go to have
dinner at gets hurt because they feel
good about themselves there is a fine
line real quick somebody breaks in the
house I say that is that that affects
people if somebody was home there was a
potential for violence someone who's
smoking weed on the corner or something
like that that's that's not affecting
anyone and I think if you start if we
start looking what we're supposed to do
is Case by case not the color skin the
con it's the content of carrying the
type of crimes non-violent crimes I'm
all for it for I don't think someone
smoking weed or doing drugs should be a
joke but there's a victim and a victim
is if I steal a car if I steal and drink
all her water she's thirsty she's a
victim okay and you make that then I
should not get to go free but if I slip
some over here and drink it there's a
difference but we have to go but but
that's why we have judges and and DA's
and we give them discretion and and
because every case is different and when
you have these ones who are screwing up
the city but it's a few of them right
it's a few of them all right we got to
go hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else